[Musique]
avec Hélène froide bien sûr bonjour
Hélène à la Une de La près cette enquête
de l'organisation forbidjan stories
histoire interdite qui a décidé comme
elle l'a fait avec d'autres de
poursuivre le travail de ce journaliste
marocain emprisonné après avoir lancé
dans son pays une enquête sur les
ex-propriations financières ce
journaliste marocain le voici il
s'appelle
Omar radis il a été condamné en mars
dernier à 6 ans de prison pour viol et
pour espionnage ces deux affaires
distinctes ont pourtant été instruite et
jugé conjointement officiellement au
maradines pas été condamné pour son
enquête sur les expropriations
financières mais le quotidien belge Le
Soir qui est partenaire de forbidden a
stories rappelle que ce journaliste
marocain a commencé à avoir des ennuis
lorsqu’amnesty international avait
révélé en juin 2020 que son téléphone
était espionné par le logiciel le
Pegasus
à la Une également ce matin la vague
d'indignation on en parlait dans le
journal en Iran après la mort la semaine
dernière de Massa mini une jeune femme
de 22 ans décédé Hélène après son
arrestation par la police des mœurs
Courrier International le magazine
relais les critiques de la presse
réformatrice iranienne qui dénonce des
abus en série depuis le durcissement de
la répression à l'encontre de femmes non
voilées mais aussi d'artistes et de
cinéastes notamment le réalisateur Jafar
panailly à qui est actuellement en
prison lui aussi critique notamment du
journal réformateur iranien amián dont
le dessinateur a dit edary a publié
cette une sur Twitter elle a été publiée
dimanche dernier et elle accuse elle a
perdu la vie pour un cheveu qui dépasse
dans le dessin Daddy et Dary on le voit
Marsa Amilly représenté comme la
dernière en date dernière victime en
date d'une série de dossiers qui
s'écroule comme des dominos d'après le
quotidien britannique de Guardian le
chef de la police des mœurs a été
suspendu aurait été suspendu de ses
fonctions à la suite de cette affaire
une information que conteste néanmoins
en France à présent la justice a
confirmé hier à avoir ouvert une enquête
après la main courante déposée par son
épouse contre le député de la France
insoumise Adrien catenens le député qui
a annoncé sa mise en retrait est
reconnue des violences envers sa femme
se retrouve au coeur d'une polémique qui
prend elle-même un tour politique
d'après Le Figaro le journal évoque
notamment la mise en cause du patron de
la France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui est accusé d'avoir minimisé cette
affaire alors que cette polémique bat
son plein une autre affaire très
médiatique elle aussi revient sur le
devant de la scène et ce matin à la Une
de Libération l'affaire Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor l'ex présentateur vedette de TF1
et de nouveaux mises en cause pour des
affaires de violence sexuelle présumées
cette fois les allégations concernent le
monde de l'édition et les deux
plaignants deux auteurs à ne coquelices
et Bénédicte Martin explique que l'effet
reproche à PPDA n'engageront pas de
poursuites puisqu'ils sont prescrits
mais qu'elles veulent appuyer à travers
leur plaintes celles déposées par
d'autres femmes avant elles les
violences faites aux femmes qui
inspirent à la dessinatrice coco ce
dessin publié également par Libération
fausse méfier des rouquins des
présentateurs télé ou JT qui c'est
encore de ces voisins s'agissent une
jeune femme auxquelles elle demande à
son voisin d'enlever sa main on ne se
quitte pas là-dessus Hélène s'il vous
plaît celles et ceux qui ne se seraient
pas lassés encore de la pompe et du Fast
de la royauté britannique je propose un
rapide coup d'oeil ou une des quotidiens
autrement ce matin et leur viennent une
dernière fois sur les cérémonies d'hier
et l’inhumation de la reine Elizabeth à
Winsor le dernier radieux titre de
Guardian impressionné je cite par la
pompe majestueuse et funèbre de ce
spectacle inégalé la reine a été avec
elle l'âge elisabethin annonce the high
prochain rendez-vous avec la royauté
britannique ce sera évidemment le
couronnement de Charles III mais pour
cela il va falloir patienter hélas
encore quelques mois il se dit Hélène
que ça pourrait même être au mois de
juin comme un clin d'œil à sa mère des
feintes merci beaucoup Hélène à tout à
l'heure